de el congreso de eeuu porque todo esto
se hizo de una manera fuerte y
bipartidista en apoyo a taiwán cuando
usted dice que soy una gran amiga de
taiwán lo tomo como un cumplido y lo
recibo en nombre de mis colegas
reconocemos y más al principio pero
estoy muy orgullosa de el partido que se
ha convertido y que los que han venido
aquí con nosotros me acaba de recordar
de la necesidad de la traducción
[Música]
mientras avanza la visita de nancy
pelosi china anunció que suspendería
algunas importaciones de frutas y
algunos otros productos seguido a la
llegada de la representante
estadounidense estas suspensiones de
importaciones se provenían normalmente
de taiwán y la prohibición entrará en
vigencia a partir de este 3 de agosto
y
estamos en directo desde france24
escuchando la intervención de la
representante estadounidense nancy
pelosi de delegados del congreso hemos
tenido tres puntos propósitos uno la
seguridad la seguridad para nuestra
gente y para el mundo el segundo es la
economía
llevar la mayor prosperidad que sea
posible y la tercera son los gobiernos y
voy a hablar sobre los tres de ellos
después de ellos después de la
traducción
de diversión sin alcohol
para mí ni exigencias de la mina ansia
diversión se sintió menguando entidad
pero a ti distancia
señor vicepresidente
y muchas de las leyes y las iniciativas
que usted mencionó fueron posibles por
los miembros de estas delegaciones
el presidente d
el comité de relaciones
internaciones exteriores del senado ha
sido nuestro líder en esta iniciativa de
defensa de los derechos humanos en el
mundo pero en particular las que usted
mencionó así que de nuevo
a parte de estos tres propósitos que
tenemos lo que queremos hacer es
convertirlos en cooperación
parlamentaria y vía lago y lo hacemos
cuando nuestro presidente
he puesto una iniciativa que apoyamos en
el pacífico sobre la cual queremos ser
específicos en la forma en la que
trabajamos en taiwán con relaciones
estamos escuchando la intervención de
nancy pelosi desde taipei y en su visita
no anunciada hasta taiwanés con las
traducciones correspondientes a chino y
posteriormente inglés
para ustedes la traducción al español
con nuestros periodistas de france 24
m
y reconocer
el liderazgo en estas iniciativas que ha
mencionado creo que tiene alguna
discusión y estoy segura que vamos a
tener algunas de estas discusiones y
venimos aquí con amistad hacia taiwán
venimos en paz para la región
nuestros en representación de nuestros
veteranos que entienden el valor de la
paz y la necesidad de evitar los
conflictos así que estoy segura que él
nos va a hablar sobre esto pero quiero
saludar lo por su protección de nuestros
veteranos no solo nuestros veteranos
sino los veteranos de todos los países
hemos hablado sobre la economía
permítanme hacer la traducción gracias
ha
explicitado